hi everyone I just want to take a few
moments to say thanks to the Believe It
or Not hundreds of thousands of people
who have sent in tweets texts emails
cards and letters wishing me well
following my recent health announcement
and I'm extremely touched by the warmth
you have expressed in your comments to
me I'm a lucky guy Alex Trebek returns
to work following his cancer diagnosis
reveal the 78 year old jeopardy host was
reportedly back on set Tuesday for the
first scheduled day of production since
this announcement last week just like
50,000 other people in the United States
each year this week I was diagnosed with
stage 4 pancreatic cancer now normally
the prognosis for this is not very
encouraging but I'm gonna fight this
that was one week ago Alex announcing
his stage four cancer diagnosis in a
message to fan Stage four is when cancer
has spread to other parts of the body
I plan to beat the low survival rate
statistics for this disease truth told I
have to because under the terms of my
contract I have to host jeopardy for
three more years
Alex will continue to host the show
while undergoing treatment for the
disease he's already begun chemotherapy
this isn't the first health struggle
alex has gone public with last year he
opened up about having brain surgery I
had a slight medical problem subdural
hematoma blood clots on the brain caused
by a fall I endured about two months ago
surgery was performed after two days in
the hospital I came home to start
recovery the prognosis is excellent and
I expect to be back in the studio taping
more jeopardy programs very very soon
Trebek has hosted the iconic gameshow
since 1984 I've been a broadcaster for
56 years
I have hosted close to 8,000 shows that
means close to half-a-million Clues I
don't remember it's a gig Trebek told et
just last year he's very grateful for
I'm a very lucky individual I'm good at
what I do and have been for a long time
but I never ever discount the importance
that luck has played in my career if I
had not been asked to host jeopardy
where would I be today I might be
teaching high school that might be
teaching the University who knows I
might still be hosting different game
shows that's quite possible but luck
plays an enormous role in anybody's
success take care buddy
[Music]
[Applause]